[Müzik]
İnsanoğlu 300 bin yıldan fazladır Bu
dünyada
Ama bu dünyada olmak bizim için her
zaman çok da kolay olmadı
nasıl yaşayacağımız ne biçim
yaşayacağımız konusunda yüz binlerce yıl
süren mücadele verdik
Ben de bugün sizlere Belki de bu
mücadelelerden elde ettiğimiz en önemli
kazanım olan özgürlükten bahsetmek
istiyorum
o zaman gelin bir hikaye ile başlayalım
hikaye insanlığın ilk ortaya çıktığı
zamanlarda geçiyor başka karakterimiz de
Özgür
hayatından memnun istediği zaman kalkar
karnı acıktığı zaman gider meyve Yok
bugün meyve değil et diyeyim diyeceği
zaman da gider avlanır
gene avlanıyor
çalının arkasına pusmuş potansiyel
avlarını bekliyor
Özgür içinde böyle bir gerginlik
Kırıntısı var çünkü Özgür biliyor ki
Ormanın kralı Özgür değil
Özgür avını Beklerken bir hışırtı
duyuyor
Özgür Gergin
Özgür o dönem artık hangi Tanrıya
inanıyorsa ona sığınarak arkasını
dönüyor
ve ne görsün Aslan
Özgür o an ecel terleri dökmeye başlıyor
Özgür o zamana kadar hiçbir aslanın
yenildiğini görmemiş Özgür
şöyle diyor ki herhalde artık Benim
zamanımda oldu diyor Böyle şişiniyor
kollarını açıyor sana doğru
ve kaçmaya başlıyor Özgür
içinde kalan en küçük enerji tanesine
kadar kaçmaya başlıyor kaçıyor da
kaçıyor kaçıyor da kaçıyor kaçıyor O da
kaçıyor
ama aslanda avını bulmuş durur mu O da
peşinden geliyor
Özgür koşarken ileride bir ışık süzmesi
görüyor Diyor ki herhalde yolun sonuna
geldik
Özgür Kollarını açıp ışığı
kucaklayacakken bir anda o ışığın diğer
insan topluluklarının yaktığı Ateş
olduğunu görüyor Özgür farkında daha
kelimeler rica edilmedi Bu yüzden Özgür
elindeki en güçlü silahı kullanıyor
çılgınlar gibi bağırmaya başlıyor
diye yardım dileniyor
insan toplulukları
Şaşkın bakıyor çünkü üstlerine kullarını
açmış gelen bir insan var ama sonra
Özgür'ün arkasındaki aslanı
gördüklerinde olayı anlıyorlar
Ondan sonra onlar da toparlanıp Özgür'e
yardıma gidiyorlar ve birlikte aslanı
yeniyorlar
Özgür Şaşkın hayatında ormanın kralını
İlk defa yeniyordu o gün özgür insan
topluluğuyla birlikte kalmaya karar
veriyor ve ömrünün sonuna kadar mutlu ve
güvenli bir biçimde yaşıyor
bunun hikayesini dinledik Özgür'ün yeni
parçası olduğu bu insan toplulukları
insan medeniyeti için vazgeçilmez
özelliğe sahiptir Bu insan toplulukları
olmadan bir insan medeniyetinden
bahsetmek dahi olasılıksızdır
bu medeniyetlerin Tabii ki dönüm
noktaları var bu insanların
medeniyetlerinin dönüm noktalarını
insanlığın çizgisinde izleyecek olursak
bir kronolojik sırayla
ilk insan topluluklarından rönesans'a
kadar 350 bin yıldan fazla geçtiğini
görürüz Peki Rönesans niye Önemli çünkü
özgürlük Fikri insanların gündemine tabi
Özgürüz falan değil sistematik olarak
Özgür hür birey anlayışı ancak rönesans
döneminde insanların gündemine
gelebilmiştir
bu fikrin bu kadar gecikmesinin Tabii ki
sebepleri var Örneğin o zamana kadar
insanlar için en önemli olan şey
güvenlikleri Çünkü Vahşi bir hayvan
saldırısını geçtim diğer devletlerin
işgali katliam yapan yüzlerce komutan
Bunların hepsi ile yüzleşmesi gerek Bu
yüzden güvenlikleri her zaman
özgürlüklerinden önce gelmişti
insanların
ancak rönesans'a doğru insanlar böyle
bir rahatlamaya başladıklarında oh
sonunda bir Özgür mü olsak ya demeye
başladıkları anda o zamana kadar onlara
Zor zamanlarında destek olan bir sığınak
olan dinler bu sefer insanların
zihinlerindeki birer hapishane haline
geldi
İnsanları her zaman koruyup kollayan
onlara tek başlarına kaldıklarında bile
bir sığınak olan dinler insanların
düşünmesini engelledi
bu dinin oluşmuş
baskıcı dogmalarının gevşemesi yüzyıllar
sürdü insanların özgürlük hakkında
kendileri hakkında düşünmelerini için
yüzlerce yıl beklemeleri gerekti
Ondan sonra bu özgürlük fikrini ilk
böyle alıştıklarında böyle ayağını ilk
soğuk suya soktuklarında İnsanlar bir
sarsıldı
Çünkü o zamana kadar
özgürlüğe dair hiçbir şey duymamışlardı
özgürlük onlar için sabah evlerinden
çıkıp
şehir merkezine gidebilmekti bunu
yapabiliyorlarsa yaşasın kralımız
Ancak bu yeni
anlayışı gündeme geldiğinde
insanlar
düşünmeye başladı çünkü yapabilecekleri
bir şey yok dünyada bunun bir örneği yok
İtalya'da Tabii küçük cumhuriyet
Devletleri var ama onlar çakma insanlar
özgürlük hakkında düşünmeye başladılar
ve o dönem yüzlerce fikir ortaya attılar
dediler böyle özgürlük olmalı Hayır öyle
olmaz böyle olmalı yüzlerce fikir ortaya
atıldı
Hatta bu dönem işte Avrupa'da aydınlanma
dönemi falan diye adlandırıldığı bu
Sanayi devrimine Ondan sonrasında artık
özgürlüğün pik noktası olan Fransız
Devrimi ne kadar devam etti
ben size Bu dönemlerde
öne çıkmış kendini farkettirmiş iki
fikirden bahsedeceğim bugün kısaca
Öncelikle
thomasops'dan bahsedeceğim Çünkü toman
sobes özgürlük fikrinin ilk gündeme
geldiği yıllarda 16 yüzyılda yaşamıştır
Rönesans ve Reform'un pik noktasına
ulaştığı bu noktada hala dünyada her yer
mutlak monarşi Tabi bu yüzden bu da
thomassopsun fikirlerini etkiliyor
o zaman adamın düşüncesi senin temeline
inelim Thomas hobbes şöyle düşünüyor
insanların
özgürlüklerini kısıtlayan hiçbir otorite
olmadığı zamanları düşünelim
en ilkel olduğumuz zamanlar Özgür'ün
yaşadığı zamanlar
o dönemlerde insanlar mutlu hiç her şey
üzerinde eşit hakları var bu önemli O
kadar Özgürüz ki her şey üzerinde eşit
hakkımız var toma soft düşünüyor
insanlar
sınırsız özgürlüğe sahip olduklarında ne
yaparlar
Düşünüyor Düşünüyor ve verdiği cevap şu
insanlar savaşırlar
insanlar savaşırlar Çünkü rahat onlara
batar
açgözlülükleri mutluluklarının önüne
geçer birbirleri ile mücadele ederler
Thomas Ops buna bir çözüm olarak
öneriyor ki bir toplum sözleşmesi
imzalayalım
tabi toplum sözleşmeleri yazılı olan
belgeler değildir ama biz kocaman toplum
olarak gelin bununla birleşelim
bu toplum sözleşmesinde Thomas Ops diyor
ki
oluşturacağımız yeni bir mutlak monarşi
olması lazım diyor
Nasıl yani biz özgür olmakla
uğraşıyorduk niye kafamıza yine bir
mutlak monarşi oturtuyoruz
cevabı şu ama soft bu mutlak monarşinin
yetkileri sınırsız olacaktır diyor ama 3
görevi olacaktır insan hürriyetini
mülkiyetini ve yaşama hakkını korumakla
görevli olacak bu Yapı
Thomas bu sınırsız güce sahip devletin
gücünü temsil etmesi adına bu yapıya
Fenike mitolojisindeki su ejderhası olan
leviatanın adını koyuyor
Thomas insanın özgürlüğünü sağlamanın
onu kısıtlamaktan geçtiğini söylüyor
onun üstüne tüm yetkilere sahip bir
Devleti koyarak onu daha özgür
yaşatacağını söylüyor
Bir de onun dışında ayrı bir fikir daha
var
ancak Russo
Jan jakusto tomas'tan yaklaşık 200 yıl
sonra yaşadığı için daha liberal daha
özgür fikirler üretebilmiştir Yani artık
kafamızın üstünde bir mutlak monarşinin
durmasına gerek yok hesabı
bu su
thomasoft'tan şuradan ayrılıyor
bizim gene sınırsız bir özgürlüğümüz var
her bireyin burada siyah çizgiyle
gösterdim
Biz mutlak özgürlüğe sahip olamayız
diyor sınırsız özgürlüğümüz olabilir ama
mutlak bir özgürlük anlayışı yoktur
diyor
Bunun sebebini de şöyle diyor
örnek vererek anlatayım
ama
ne zaman ki sizler içeri geldiniz benim
özgürlük alanım bu sahne kadar oldu
Cancan beni söylüyor bir bireyin
özgürlüğünü kısıtlayan tek şeyi ancak
bir direğin direği diğerinin
özgürlüğüdür
Buna da şöyle karşı çıkar
diyor ki
benim özgürlüğüm konferans salonu
kadarken bir sahneye tıkıldı
ama sizin de hiç özgürlüğünüz yokken
konferans salonunun çoğunluğunu aldınız
bu Orantısız kısıtlamayı önlemek için
can-jack russo'da tomasoops gibi bir
toplum sözleşmesi öneriyor Hatta ünlü
toplum sözleşmesinin yazarı da aslında
kendisidir
bu toplum sözleşmesinin amacı İnsanların
özgürlüğünü Orantısız derecede
kısıtlamayı dengelemek Ancak bu da şu
yüzden önemlidir ki; buna tüm halkın
fiilen katılması gerekir
Bunları sağladığımızda belki kendi
özgürlüklerimizden feragat edeceğiz Ama
sivil ve ahlaki olarak
mutluluğa ve Bir dereceye kadar
özgürlüğe erişmiş olacağız diyor Ancak
Rusya
bu iki düşününü dinledik Peki bu
düşünürler nerede birleşiyor birisi
tamamen mutlak monarşi tamamen
Cumhuriyeti savunuyor
bunların birleştiği nokta
düşüncelerinin temeline insanın Doğa
durumunu almalarıdır
insan çünkü
doğadadır
insanın özgürlüğüne gelen müdahaleler
olmadan önce insan doğada özgürlüğünü
Yaşar
insan ama doğadakilerden ayrılır Çünkü
İnsanın aklı vardır insan düşünür fikir
üretir özgürlük üzerine düşünür
Biz doğadakilerden Aklımızdan
ayrılıyoruz Ama şu çok önemli dedi ki
insan
doğadakilerden ayrı ama doğanın bir
parçasıdır
insan doğada özü ile birdir
insan özüyle baş başa kaldığında ancak
özünü hisseder ve özünü düşünür
bu kadar özgürlükten bahsettik
başka karakterimiz özgürlüğü düşünelim
Özgür doğada özgürdü
Ancak ve ancak özünü
gürlettiği zaman özgürlüğü yaşayabildi
O yüzden şunu söylemek Bence kesinlikle
yanlış olmaz
özgürlük de kendimizi anlayıp
ona göre uyarladığımız zaman olur
Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]